okay i think we're on the air steve
goffin here
for another session as we compare notes
on our 90-day challenge
and what we're experiencing or i talk
about my experience and i get your
comments and questions
so i i gave this
presentation or this discussion today a
title the the biggest conundrum in
language learning
now a conundrum is a sort of a
dilemma or a problem that we struggle
with should we do this or should we do
that
um
and to me and and the reason i thought
about this is is a couple of factors
first of all
uh i had i find myself in my arabic like
i spoke with my arabic tutor yesterday
and i really struggle
to speak the verbs in arabic are tough
past tense present tense the
form of the verb there are certain
elements that are constant but they
change depending on gender
depending on you know past tense present
tense the
suffix changes the
prefix changes it's there's a lot there
to try to
you know you can know in theory that
this happens but to try to remember the
form of the verb that you're to use now
and then if you use a negative like la
les
lem
you've got other options so it's all
very difficult you can read the rules
but it's very difficult to do
uh in contrast persian is a lot easier
uh and i felt you know when i was only
listening to the mini stories
i actually was speaking better
because the mini stories focus on verbs
and so
the same story might appear in the
present tense and the past tense
it might appear in you know as
i did something and then he or she did
something so you're exposed to the
different forms of these very common
verbs so they start ringing in your
brain and then you're able to use them
because you're not relying on memory
you're relying on a sort of instinctive
you know reflexibility to produce
something that you've heard
so as long as i stayed on the mini
stories then i was better in
speaking
but of course i'm not expanding my
vocabulary now the last little while
i've been listening to these difficult
you know discussions from podcast al
jazeera franz badcat
and so there i'm acquiring new words
some of which stick words like elections
or candidate or uh
situation or you know all those kinds of
uh words
uh but in fact my ability to speak is is
suffering a bit
uh one problem we have is that
that we don't have enough sort of
intermediate content at uh link and
intermediate content should be shorter
like if it's a 15 minute
podcast or a 40 minute podcast it's too
long because i like to listen more than
once so if it's 40 minutes then i'm not
getting that intensive sort of
repetition that i would like ideally
ideally there would be five-minute
uh discussions discussions are great
because typically
they're easier uh you know conversations
on history politics you name it
uh we don't have that if anybody out
there who is a speaker of arabic or
persian can provide that that would be
great for us
so this so i have this conundrum um
you know do i focus on getting better at
speaking by
staying with simple content
uh reviewing some of the grammar tables
or whatever sort of trying to nail
things down so that i can perform better
when i speak to my tutor
or
do i
focus more on the sort of long-term
strategy
of expanding my vocabulary slowly
reading and listening to a broad range
of material
so that in the long run i will be able
to understand those
and in the long run i know from
experience i will eventually be able to
speak but in the short term
i will be every week in speaking to my
tutor struggling
badly now i get the report back from the
tutor i go over the words and phrases
that cause difficulty so to some extent
i am improving i think i am improving i
mean the more you speak the more you
improve
but it's always a struggle so to me that
is a big conundrum
and i had a comment here from daniel
daniel singh if i remember correctly who
said that
he was very thankful to me for pointing
out that listening comprehension
is really the core
competence the core skill in language
learning
because as long as he was under the
impression
that the core skill was to be able to
speak well so then he was trying to
speak well and he wasn't succeeding and
he said that he was an introvert
who knows you know people say they're
introverts everyone likes to communicate
at some level with people they're
comfortable with
uh but he was not successful in his
communicating so this was disappointing
and frustrating insofar as his language
learning was concerned but once he
started focusing on listing
comprehension as the main goal
then all of a sudden his language
competence overall improved and
presumably his ability to speak
also improved so
the conundrum then is you know in a
classroom setting where a teacher
teaches you something and then drills
you on it and then wants you to engage
in some in a sort of role-playing
discussion wants you to perform wants
you to
show that you learned or you can
produce these skills
you know is that the way to go that's
the way
most language learning is structured
you know get the basics get the basics
the the
and i'm kind of
caught in that because i want to do well
when i speak to my tutor but i know that
the more i try to sort of get the basics
improve my grasp on verbs in arabic
in order to do better in my conversation
i'm delaying my progress
in the broader exposure to the language
acquisition of vocabulary
getting used to hearing it getting used
to understanding it
and actually
that's going to do me more good in the
long run so we have to decide if we have
a short term strategy maybe we never
want to get beyond that ability to say a
few things okay we're going to go to
mexico on holidays we want to be able to
say a few things in spanish we have no
you know uh
desire to understand the radio
understand movies understand uh
you know the the television whatever we
just want to be able to say a few things
so then we focus entirely on say the
mini stories or some simple
form of content but if our goal is to
become you know broadly competent in the
language then we have to sort of
force ourselves out of the comfort zone
of the sort of simple learner content
trying desperately once again to nail
down the subjunctive or to nail some
other aspect of the language just let it
go don't worry about it focus on
listening comprehension as your primary
goal
in the confidence that in the long run
if you achieve a high level of listening
comprehension
competence ability to understand at that
point then the speaking will come and
eventually you have to speak a lot i'm
not suggesting you can just become
you know brilliantly fluent one day
without speaking a lot you have to speak
a lot but if you start to speak a lot
based on having this high level of
listening comprehension
uh i think that's that's better but it's
difficult to do and that's the conundrum
is to not be tempted to try to
sort of uh
really hone those basic skills
at an early stage
if that's taking time away from
expanding in the language now if you
have eight hours a day you can do both
but if you have an hour to two hours a
day then i think the focus and that's
the conundrum that i'm struggling with
uh you know i want to do well with my
tutor but i want to expand in my arabic
persian is easier so it's easier not to
sound so silly when i'm speaking to my
tutor uh but i haven't gone very far in
terms of expanding my vocabulary in
persia i've only got 2000 words if you
know if i were to pull a news article
off the internet it would be full of
blue unknown words so i have a sort of a
higher degree of competence in a more
limited vocabulary in persian
but if i were to
strike up a conversation with someone
then
we can only talk about very lim a very
limited number of things so
that's what i struggle with and of
course it helps a lot
and we have that in other languages not
in arabic or persian but in other
languages we have five minute content
medium difficulty
ideal content to me is conversations for
that intermediate category
because typically people in
conversations don't use
uh you know as many you know low
frequency words
uh it's more lively and if we have
lively conversations transcribed five
minutes long on a variety of subjects
that's kind of helpful to help you
get from the basic
simple
content into the real authentic content
that's going to take you to your final
goal so there you have it i that to me
is the big conundrum do you try to nail
down
your basic skills you know nail down
some aspects of verbs and i think verbs
are key uh or
do you push yourself into sort of more
difficult content where
for a long time it can seem as if
you know you don't see the words often
enough for them to really stick and you
feel like you're not making progress
although i should say
that if i listen to persian i really
don't people talking about some random
subject i don't understand much at all
in arabic now
i understand i know what they're talking
about i pick up words
i definitely sense that my listening
comprehension has improved and i have
close to 8 000 words i know that if i
continue linking and saving and
reviewing that the 8 000 is going to
grasp slowly move to nine and ten and
twelve and fifteen thousand and at
fifteen thousand words i'll understand
an awful lot more in other words i know
from experience that as frustrating as
it may
feel at times
that we're not remembering the words and
it continuously you know i just kind of
half understand and stuff i just know
that it's only a matter of time that
you i won't lose anything i will only
get better
which isn't true of my golf okay now
let's see what the questions are here
okay
let me go to the beginning here
at first blah blah blah
no no no no dutch is close enough no no
no no do you ever try to avoid reading
things written before say the 18th
century to avoid antiquated
vocabulary structures
um
it depends on the language
but uh you know
certainly
19th century
literature has been a major source of my
learning
uh in spanish you know you can read don
quixote or
what was that other one i can't remember
it doesn't really matter i think that
i'm interested in acquiring
words i'm interested in reading and
listening to things that that i'm
interested in and the century doesn't
matter
i have never worried about you know
acquiring archaic expressions because
eventually i would listen to so much of
the language that's that some portion of
it that was archaic it doesn't it
doesn't bother me at all uh no i would
say the answer to that is no
oh
i love you steve oh thank you that's
very kind of you
uh
warrior angel for god
after msa which dialect will you focus
on i'm thinking about starting with 11
team then going to msa okay this is from
uh so i don't know
uh
you know i'm going to be involved with
arabic for a long time languages are not
a hit and miss or a hit and run type of
activity
you've got to put in the time and so i
mean russian and slavic languages have
been with me now for 10 years and i
enjoy them and i enjoy that relationship
chinese has been with me for 50 years uh
arabic is not gonna be part of
my understanding of the world
so
yeah i'm gonna learn msa for a while and
then if it should be that i'm gonna
visit or i meet people say in vancouver
who are from syria then i'll learn
levantine
arabic
or palestinians or whatever
if i'm going to be in if i want to if i
get interested in watching egyptian uh
soap opera on netflix i might
fish in arabic uh just as i have i mean
you know my
portuguese i listen to spanish
like spanish from spain spanish from
latin america portuguese it's all
variations on a theme i
can't give you an answer
is it possible in your opinion that
someone can give excellent
listing comprehension and yet speak very
poorly or will the comprehension will
automatically make him a decent speaker
no good comprehension listening
comprehension doesn't guarantee
that you will be a good speaker you
still have to speak you have to speak a
lot
however the better your listening
comprehension the better you will speak
every time
i
i hear people say you know oh you know i
i read and listen well but i can't speak
so then i say well can you understand an
audiobook no
have you read a novel no
so if you can understand an audiobook if
you can read the novel the same
audiobook you're well on your way to
being able to speak but you still have
to get out there and speak
um so it's not automatic but it's it's a
sort of a precondition not to mention
the fact that if you're in a natural
conversation with someone and you don't
understand what they're saying that's
very uncomfortable both for you and for
the other person so
i think good listening comprehension is
a precondition for speaking well but
eventually you still have to get it out
and speak steve have you ever been to
thailand or the philippines yes i have
been to both places
uh how do you study your audiobooks and
books in link intermediate okay so
take an example of polish
but ukrainian is the same you find an
audiobook
online you search for it in different
ways
for which an ebook is also available
then you can import the ebook into link
there's a book importing function at
link uh but the audio i just listened on
uh you know out of itunes on my phone
i'm not gonna bother trying to break the
audio up into sort of sound sections
that correspond to the chapters of the
book on link is just too much work so to
some extent
all of that listening is not measured by
link because link will only measure what
you listen in the lesson or if you have
downloaded the lesson audio to a
playlist and every time you listen on
the playlist it also registers it but uh
yeah i uh that's how i do it so i
understand english but don't know the
exact meaning of many words which i
understand when i hear someone speaking
can we go and check their miniature
i mean if you listen to someone and you
don't understand it it's so difficult to
go looking words up uh i think you just
have to continue
with
a program like link where you are
gradually increasing your vocabulary
listening reading saving words reviewing
listening reading and eventually you'll
understand more and more yeah you can't
in a conversation start looking words up
to any significant extent
steve would you check my stats on link
like you did on your last okay
okay i will but i won't do it now i will
do it next time so i have here your
username and i will look you up the next
time
what is your eating habits do you think
any specific food affects your learning
you're skipping a meal no i don't uh
i won't get into more of my eating
habits
it's simply a matter of uh we tend to
have a late
breakfast
uh
you know oatmeal fruit
and then try to get through most of the
day and have an early dinner
typically with
you know vegetables and
some meat and stuff like that i tend not
to eat so many carbohydrates at night
but i don't think diet has anything to
do with language learning
uh
okay
alaikum okay
what do you think of reading aloud does
it change anything in comparison with
reading silently well i don't know the
answer to that
i i think it's a matter of what you like
to do
it's tiring to read aloud so i tend not
to do it
when we read in a language that's new we
tend to sub-vocalize so to some extent
you are sounding the words out in your
mind but i don't do a lot of reading
aloud so i can't really comment too much
ah let's see if you know arabic steve
so
i i as i said uh i don't really speak it
very well ana lasted
um
i'm not good at speaking arabic but i'm
getting there if you follow the the main
gist of my
uh
comments today it's that uh
i am uh constantly you know
confront i confront the fact that i
don't speak very well but i still want
to
push forward and what matters is not how
well i speak now what matters is how
well will i speak a year from now
i import an audiobook from youtube i
assume the system separate the content
in three parts but third part is missing
instead i got two second part
uh that if you have a technical issue
like that it could be any number of
things
relating to the content that you
imported and so forth
the best place to talk about that is on
the forum because other people may have
had a similar experience or it may be
unique to the com
the content that you imported
sorry i can't give you more than that
when learning the romance languages do
you think there is any particular order
to follow
well i mean i have this perception that
spanish is the easiest so i would start
with spanish
but uh i think the bigger issue is just
how motivated you are
okay email to
link support
uh you know
just to make 100
yeah email link support you should get
an answer
uh how much listening do you do for a
language when you're at intermediate 2
and wanting to go to advanced
um
well i don't set myself a specific goal
i listen as much as i'm able to fit in
during the day and typically that's uh
a matter of um
what i'm doing so i will listen uh while
making breakfast and cleaning up i will
listen uh if i go to the store on my
bicycle i will listen if i work out in
the gym
those are the kinds of places when i
listen i don't sit down to deliberately
listen okay do you think you are fluent
in italian
uh i mean italian is kind of ninth or
tenth on my list of languages uh if i'm
there surrounded by italians i'm able to
carry on a conversation but certainly
not as fluent as let's say spanish
is it really difficult to learn russian
is the question well depends what you
call
it's fun to learn russian it's
interesting i love it
there are some real grammar issues in
all the slavic languages
that continue to confound me uh
very difficult to produce the cases
endings you know of nouns and adjectives
accurately while speaking very difficult
to get the right form of you know the
the the
aspect of the verb and the right verb
emotion and so there are difficulties
but there are difficulties in every
language
the main thing is how motivated you are
well i've stopped i did the romanian for
a specific purpose i was going to be in
romania
for for uh five days actually but i
spent two months learning romanian
i spoke enough
that i was kind of able to fight my way
through uh history podcasts on radio
romania
and i was able to communicate while in
romania but i haven't done anything in
it now so
i think i would have great difficulty
speaking
in romanian
now are you going to sergey or bosnia on
link i have a lots of friends here from
there i would love to learn to
understand what they're talking about
okay
i would love to have
serbo croat bosnia whatever i think the
language is more or less won
on link
if you have friends from there
if they will agree and we will even pay
them some
get us
you know translate our many stories
and and
record them
uh and on the iphone or android is fine
good quality recording and give us those
and we will upload them and we will
start servo creation so roswolf if you
can get your friends to do that for us
and provide and find us additional
content
then we will do it and i think
i don't know whether we put it up in in
the latin alphabet or cyrillic or both
but we'll put it up if you can get us
the content
uh have you started with books like
teach yourself arabic or persian if so
what are they okay
uh in arabic the books are not very good
i have i don't have the books here handy
uh with persian i have both living
language
and colloquial
and they have their advantages and
disadvantages i use them basically for
content i also have asimil in both
persian and arabic i i find asi mail a
lot of their content is kind of
too obtuse too sort of
they're trying to be so cute and clever
all the time
and uh so i mean and that's a small part
of the content that i listen to but i
listen to a variety of things i don't
just listen to our mini stories although
i've spent more time listening to the
mini stories than any other content how
many years did you spend on italian not
very many because i had the french i had
the spanish and so i think at one point
i bought linguaphone and i spent some
time listening to that
and then i got uh
i was listening to some content that
link
uh you know trying to get a better
handle on some of the structures of
italian
and then i did a lot of listening to
audiobooks that was a big part of it
from
naratore
and i listened to pinocchio his version
of pinocchio is phenomenal we have that
at link by the way
and the ipremesis posie which italians
consider a very boring book but
for me it was uh
you know connecting with the history and
in italy and stuff
and then i listened to a lot of uh
i do it
lots of podcasts
which now by the way if i i really
recommend this
i had i do it but i had no transcripts
i didn't really need the transcripts
because i have most of the vocabulary
but if you don't have the vocabulary now
you can go to
automatic transcription sites and have
these podcasts transcribed and they are
it's a phenomenal source
now how should one balance learning more
than one language is it better not to
learn more than two languages at a time
well i used to think it was better to
learn one language and i must say that
it is a bit of a struggle now to be
trying to do arabic and persian at the
same time i'm going three days on one
three days on the other
there's some discussion should i go two
weeks on one two weeks on the other i'm
afraid that i'll forget too much if i do
it that way
every time i leave the one i'm kind of
sorry to have to leave it because i just
feel i'm starting to make some progress
and then i gotta go to the other
so it's difficult to say experiment see
what works for you what is more powerful
reading or listening cheers from alarusa
you know to me listening is what
sort of
listening is momentum for reading
listening is what's going to enable you
to speak listening is kind of getting
the language in you and training but
reading is where i pick up vocabulary i
find it very difficult to remember words
just by listening
uh
no in both the question did i try to
learn some words before i was in the
philippines like i don't know 50 years
ago so i didn't try to learn anything
similar with thailand
a long long time ago if
thailand again i would definitely try to
learn some words uh similarly with the
philippines although
one has the impression of the
philippines
is more of an english-speaking
environment and uh i would kind of be
concerned that people would simply
answer me in english whereas in thailand
i don't know but yeah in either case if
i were to go there now i would try to
learn some of the language
how are you finding the arabic script
compared to sir liquor chinese
characters well chinese characters is
the most work
because there's so many of them i had to
learn 4000 or so
cyrillic is not difficult at all
because it's
almost parallel to
the
latin script
it's a little confusing because some of
the letters in cyrillic that looked like
letters
in
the latin script are pronounced
differently so because it takes time to
get used to anything
even when you're reading comfortably in
cyrillic every so often you'll see
what looks like a p
er
and try to pronounce it p when in fact
it's an r
uh the arabic script is
more difficult much more difficult than
the cyrillic for a number of reasons
initially it's hard to get into because
it has a different form each letter has
a different form depending on its
location in the word
uh second of all
uh
you know it's it's not obvious what the
vowel is now they do have this sort of
uh
how to cut system for
suggesting the
vowel but it's not used
widely um so it's it's a problem
in a way it's a bit like uh chinese
characters you almost have to know the
word before you can pronounce it so it's
difficult
uh when it comes to german listening and
reading
steve why when it comes to german
listening and reading doesn't work
i found that it works
uh i was unable to make any progress
in um
in german as long as i was trying to
remember
the das
the minute i stopped doing that and
started doing a lot of listening and
reading my german just took off
so i don't know why you would say that
that has not been my experience
uh
now what is your opinion on word
memorization versus just reading at your
level well i don't do any word
memorization i do some
review of
uh
words
as i go from page to page in my lessons
but again not with the goal of
memorizing just with the goal of having
this other sort of concentrated exposure
to these words before i move on
steve if you could go back and talk to
your younger self what advice would you
give yourself with regard to language
learning perhaps something you wish
okay
um
nothing really because i think
everything i have done has been to
expose myself to the language
through lots of listening and reading i
did it initially with french when i
basically took responsibility for my
french learning stop worrying about what
was happening in the class at school
and uh
you know
read listened eventually went to france
similarly with chinese i did a lot of
listening reading nothing much has
changed in so far as my strategy what
has changed is the tremendous
technological advance mp3
players mp3 files access to material on
the internet systems like link
so everything has become much much much
easier
i feel i have to amanda panda says i
feel i have to read this at the same
time i can't understand whole words
instead of all the difficulty do you
suggest me listening
well
um
first of all i find that at an early
stage of the language and even now in
arabic i cannot keep up if i try to
listen and read at the same time i can't
read as fast as what i'm hearing
so
but i do some i attempt to do
sort of some listening and reading at an
early stage
because i think it's good training for
my reading and then thereafter i don't i
just listen when i listen and i read
when i read
[Music]
when considering reading material how
would you balance the difficulty level
in other words what percentage of total
reading should be easier
at level or difficult
again i go by what i feel like doing
i think there should be some difficult
and some easy the difficult in order to
you know mine it for new words and
phrases
easy stuff to reinforce it
um
again i don't read books or magazines
until i'm stronger in the language
because i don't like reading material
with lots of words that i don't
understand without having access to an
online dictionary
ah
how's the
indica
can african sprott no but i understood
that
no soma line and also no what is your
opinion on the word memorization i think
i answered that hello when are you going
to start learning turkish
uh okay i my goal is
this year
uh so i've got my 90 day challenge in
arabic and persian
then i'm going to be going to ukraine
for two weeks
mostly in kiev and eastern ukraine
where i will be speaking mostly russian
a little bit of
ukrainian
and
so then i'll come back so then from june
on because i'm going to the polyglot
conference in fukuoka i was thinking you
know it's a good opportunity and a good
excuse to focus on getting my korean up
to the next level so i might just focus
on my korean so all of this means that
by the time i get back to my middle
eastern languages in november they will
be in a sort of sad state so i might
focus back on them again
which would mean that turkish would
start in the beginning of 2020. my best
guess
okay uh so i think link is great what
other platform
what app
i don't know because i don't use other
apps um basic romanian and we have a
fair amount of basic romanian at link
at some there are other uh romanian
resources available on the internet if
you google you'll find them
um
and at some point you can start
listening to radio romania and you can
now get it transcribed with these
automatic transcription services and you
can import those transcripts to link
that would be my strategy greetings from
chile
uh greetings i visited chile in 1981.
would you recommend learning a language
such as french friendship german through
reading and writing then going through
the process of learning verbally
i you know i learn everything
all at the same time
reading
writing well i don't write much but
reading and listening
those two those prepare you to write and
speak so reading and listening
regardless of the language
rich meister once you have the
translations and recordings how long
does it take to get them on the website
i live in georgia and i can have any of
my friends do the ministries oh
georgian all right
uh not long i mean if you get us the 60
mini stories and you can contact me
steve link.com i will send you the uh
the english or the russian whichever is
easier for your friends
um
although you can find it on the site
and uh once they have it done then it's
a question of
our tech person has to we have to find
some dictionaries so again if you can
suggest some online dictionaries for
georgian
because that has to be there
then when they have the time to set it
up they'll set it up
so i can't give you anything more
definite than that do you find it
feasible and efficient to learn 100
words a day uh
my experience has been
that learning the way i learn at linc
uh
i learn 100 words a day it depends on
the language but if it's a language with
the same alphabet pretty soon your so
many words that are being added to your
known words total
are being picked up incidentally and in
fact if i if i divide and the number of
my known words by the number of days
that i've been studying i'm always above
100 words a day
[Music]
okay
okay i mean i'm not about to learn it
but if i were going to go there i would
certainly put some effort into doing so
uh which books do you recommend for
swedish and portuguese
i mean my approach is that
almost any of the starter books
is just content so typically i buy two
starting books it could be teach
yourself could be cold
will
um
and i do the content in both
um
and then i work on the many stories that
link and that's that's so
or you can get
doesn't matter
okay how long did it take you to learn
swedish it's a long story i was born in
sweden lived until i was five
i forgot the language
went back there at the age of 16 spent
two months over summer
uh
and then i ended up doing a lot of
business in sweden
so i got totally interested in swedish i
got uh you know
there's a man in sweden called hermann
lindqvist who writes about swedish
history and has recorded his history
books
and i just listened to those over and
over again
audiobooks are great and sweden has
tremendous audio books and if you can
find the the text for them
then that's great learning material
have you found that certain countries
cultures are less receptive to your
effort to speak their language
um i would say that everyone is
receptive
uh some people are more effusive in
their
support uh
you know for example i mean i found the
iranians around vancouver
if i even say three words of persian
they're just beside themselves and very
appreciative
um
some people are less so i don't want to
say
but
certainly uh
japanese chinese persian brazilian all
those people are very
appreciative
some people kind of take it for granted
french
you speak french you don't speak french
it depends on the individual i think
it's unfair to generalize
just want to say that you are crazy to
learn arabic and farsi at the same time
good for you though yeah i'm crazy i buy
that what's your main motivation for
learning new languages in general
okay motivation for learning new
languages
i mean i have a totally different
perception
of say arabs the arabic world or persian
and iran
now than i have even though i haven't
gone very far in those languages it's
it's you
you know i live in this world for a
specific period of time and it's it it's
the greatest way
to explore
other countries it it's almost better
than going there uh so
the only problem is you can't do it in
two weeks so every language is a
commitment of a year of two but uh yeah
that's the uh that's the motivation
uh
how to follow the reading about approach
when you're learning a language so
different such as japanese and chinese a
good amount of character yeah you have
to make that investment in learning the
characters both for japanese and chinese
it's it's a big job it's a big
investment of time but it's worth it and
then once you have that then the more
reading you do the better you're going
to be able to you know handle the
characters
okay link teachers thank you okay i keep
forgetting steve do you think reading
translations into the target language is
any less valuable than reading text that
were originally written
so translations are easier because
typically someone translating doesn't
use the same
breadth of vocabulary i mean if you read
the harry potter in japanese it's going
to be easier than
a japanese novel so to that extent it's
kind of intermediate content so
translations i think are good
uh
how do i get motivated to read something
mediocre in my target language
well you gotta look for it
uh
i can't uh tell you
polish isn't it is a supported language
at link yes it may have been beta but
it's not
what is your goal in learning languages
i mean it can be fun and get your brain
informed but as you said if you focus on
one you notice a lack on the other and
start over again
my goal is to discover these languages
and along the way i developed the
ability to communicate
if you can make a community contrib
contribution to content link send a
email to steveatlink.com
how much
how much time does it take to be level
c1 or c3 well depends what your starting
point is depend what languages you know
it depends how much time you put in i
can't answer that
how to teach english to kids i mean i
would focus on letting them enjoy
stories listen to stories read stories
and not worry about what they can say
uh
how to overcome the upper intermediate
learning slump no
i have nothing to suggest other than
when you are at the upper intermediate
level you are now able to enjoy the
language you can read anything of
interest listen to anything of interest
so just go and enjoy the language and
you will gradually improve
start swedish from basic i would say the
same advice as i gave earlier go and buy
one or two starter books or borrow them
at your library and then get on link
where's a good place to buy ebooks that
i can upload to link or does it depend
on the language i'm looking for chinese
well you would have to translate
ebook on whatever subject
and google and see what you come up with
if you had two hours a day to learn
chinese but you still do flash cards to
learn the characters i can't say because
there are better
um
better
resources now than there were
uh i i can't comment but um
certainly learning the characters would
be a big
goal steve tested out of arabic at an
intermediate advanced level after six
months i think was very helpful we'll
continue to use the system to improve
these two languages and eventually add
some dialects will i guess you say will
you continue yeah we would like to see
more content at link if people can give
uh us content or something we'll
actually pay
to help get some more content i
recognize that we need more arabic
content both in uh msa like standard
arabic and in various other forms
levantine golf
um egyptian and so forth
okay i'm going to stop it here and thank
you everyone for uh
okay let's see we got a few more here as
any japanese i still remember such a
pain to learn chinese characters in
school
it's a pain but once you have them you
have them and and it opens up i mean you
can't get into the whole chinese world
without the characters and japan
japanese while the language is different
it's part of that whole chinese cultural
world so is korean and i think it's very
unfortunate that korea no longer has
chinese characters
uh
okay
okay i'm gonna have to leave now
thank you for listening bye for now